NARRATOR: Despite the
growing popularity of trucks
in the early 1900s, buyers
were caught in a quagmire
as infrastructure lagged.
We like to joke that,
at that time, you know,
there were two kinds
of roads-- either
bad roads or no roads at all.
It was not uncommon for
vehicles to get stuck,
even in good weather.
And then, of course,
in wet weather,
it was like driving
through quicksand.
NARRATOR: Autos were stuck in
the world of two-wheel drive,
with rear wheels pushing
them forward as front wheels
were left clear to steer.
But then a pair of blacksmiths
from Clintonville, Wisconsin,
had an unfortunate episode
at their part-time job.
Otto Zachow and William
Besserdich sold REO cars.
And they were driving a
REO car, and it got stuck.
The only way they
could get it unstuck
is William drove it backwards.
And that gave him
an inspiration--
powering all four wheels.
NARRATOR: It's an idea that
would become a defining feature
of trucks forever--
if they could pull it off.
It's like to trucks in one.
You have the regular
drive going out the rear.
But then you have to have
a transfer case that also
sends power to a front axle.
And that front
axle has to steer.
Zachow and Besserdich are
credited with coming up with
a universal ball joint that
would allow the front wheels
to steer and simultaneously
receive power from the drive
shaft, which was
the breakthrough
that made four-wheel drive
technology practical.
NARRATOR: Zachow and
Besserdich's double wide joint,
patented in 1908,
became the centerpiece
of their groundbreaking
new passenger
car, dubbed the Battleship.
The Battleship became the
flagship of the blacksmiths'
new car business,
the aptly named Four
Wheel Drive Company, or FWD.
And eventually,
FWD caught the eye
of a very powerful customer.
The Army ordered a
fleet of military trucks
with FWD technology.
It would get a trial
by fire in 1917.
FWD produced more than
24,000 trucks for World War I.
Four-wheel drive was
absolutely indispensable
to the success of vehicles
during World War I,
because the conditions
there were just terrible.
The rain was constant.
The mud was everywhere.
And of course, it's
literally a battlefield
that you're having to drive
across, in some cases.
So it was a great advantage
to have that during the war.
NARRATOR: FWD returned from
Europe as a conquering hero.
The world war had given
this company a big victory
in the truck wars.
And with such
innovative founders,
they might have
established a dynasty.
But there was one problem.
Zachow and Besserdich
both sold out
their interests soon
after the Four Wheel
Drive Company was established.
Otto Zachow returned
to his machine shop
for the rest of his life.
NARRATOR: Although the Four
Wheel Drive Company still
exists today under
the name FWD Seagrave,
they aren't a household
name for one simple reason.
The brand was built really
around a single technology,
and that has never proven a
long term way to build a brand.
Everybody could adopt
that technology.
So what's left to
hang your hat on?
NARRATOR: But one look at
the modern truck landscape,
and the impact of that one
simple idea is undeniable.
The legacy of the Four Wheel
Drive Company is immense.
I can't imagine-- and I bet
you can't either-- a world
without four wheel drive.